[Musique]
vendredi soir tf1 diffusait la grande
finale de koh lanta les quatre ter une
saison qui a fait parler mais qui a
aussi divisé
c'est donc alexandra qui a remporté
cette saison une saison à laquelle la
production avait tenté de donner un coup
de neuf
en proposant pour la toute première fois
quatre triples
on utilise qui a chamboulé les habitudes
de certains fans
du côté des épreuves rien de neuf sous
les tropiques toujours du manioc des
poteaux et quelques épreuves de confort
toujours aussi gourmande une saison
également marqué dès son commencement
par la disparition tragique de bertrand
kamel l'un des candidats mort d'un
cancer quelques jours seulement après le
début de la diffusion du jeu un hommage
lui a été rendu lors de la finale en
présence de ses parents il ya ce foulard
vert qui appartenait qui appartient
encore à bertrand kamel une saison qui a
convaincu en moyenne 5,52 millions
téléspectateurs un score inférieur à la
précédente saison diffusée au printemps
qui avait particulièrement marqué les
esprits durant le premier confinement
alors cette saison de koh-lanta est-elle
à la hauteur des attentes
pascal anciens candidats de koh lanta et
sur notre plateau pour débriefer la
saison
alors pascal déjà merci d'être là mon
pascal je suis heureux de te voir on a
eu des cas on en a eu des spl scheinin
tous les deux et pascal suis très
content de te voir parce que il ya brice
qui sera avec nous à finaliser de cette
saison qui sera avec nous un instant en
v stein mais toi tu voulais que tu sois
là parce que je trouve que s'il ya un
reproche qu'on peut faire cette année à
la saison de koh lanta c'est que ils
étaient tous très sympa les candidats
tout ça mais il manquait des personnages
hauts en couleur comme tu as pu l'être
ou toi à moi tu me faisais on a été
plusieurs éléments dire oui est ce que
ta taille mais toi cette saison de koh
lanta ou pas alors moi je suis passionné
par laventure ouais d'accord et depuis
je la regarde depuis très longtemps faut
pas oublier que ça vient du sud depuis
survivor bien sûr à la base mais à la
base c'était une aventure de gros
stratégie parce que petit à petit la
stratégie s'efface ouais et là sur cette
saison moi ce que j'ai aimé c'est les
paysages voir la mer nous croyons et du
regard des valeurs et la wii sa manche
pour les gros passionnés à savoir qui
est un groupe en parallèle que le bit
forum on est des gros passionnés et on
aime les gros stratégie et et à leurs
excuses aujourd'hui je les trouve tous
liste parce que derrière ils savent
qu'il va y avoir un retour sur les
réseaux sociaux
il va y avoir beaucoup ils ont peur de
dérision peur ils sont de plus en plus
jeunes
il ya demain la majorité devient jeune
comparé à vent et à vue il ya des
réactions très violentes sur les réseaux
sociaux pour koh lanta c'est donc ça
peut faire changer ça des frênes et
comme ils sont jeunes et du coup ben
voilà ils sont gentils ils cassent la
flèche s'est aggravée et c'est dommage
alors les joueurs eux-mêmes bravo parce
que faire 40 jours quoiqu'il en soit une
repli bien sûr c'est toujours très dur
faire l' aventure ça reste quelque chose
une épreuve très compliqué dans la vie
mais pour moi pelé tapis depuis on va
dire depuis 2016 petit à petit ça
descend sa descente il ya plus en la
stratégie devient quelque chose de
malhonnête de compliqué celui qui la
ramène bc war à l'heure où un [ __ ]
ou donc tu penses que tu penses que les
réseaux sociaux sont en train c'est à
dire complètement les réseaux sociaux
affaibli sont à milford après koh lanta
ils se disent épi sans compter que vous
avez deux catégories vous avez ce qui
vaut qui dispute un jeu faire que l'on
table parce que derrière bambach
influence pour lower et tout ce qui
s'ensuit bien sûr ça ça détruit un peu
ouais et de l'autre côté il ya ceux qui
fut ainsi jeudi selon me massacrer
bien sûr on va s'en prendre sujet les
mines
un tel joueur à béchir à 6,6 j'élimine
telle femme je suis misogyne c'est très
très compliqué forme
ouais et vous joué avec le coeur est
arrivé là-bas alors bien sûr à 50 piges
je me dis moi je m'en fous je suis j'en
vois toi je t'ai les mines c'est pas une
histoire de couleur de quoi que ce soit
tu te fait massacrer c'est pas grave
c'est toute l'histoire de majorité tu
t'es fait massacrer tout sur l'airé et
ça continue sans arrêt on verra je suis
là ce soir je me fais ma façon à casser
soi mais c'est pas grave c'est pas grave